Not disputing that 15 bodies have been
found, have you? Eight of them are Red
Cres red cresant workers.
Look, um I think that if I haven't heard
about this
case, look at the tomb. This is crazy.
Shifted. You know what happened?
Somebody in the back gave her something.
If that phone had not been found in that
poor soul's
[Music]
pocket, we want to establish an amazing
masid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala. in the country of Norway. Click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends
I'm here with Zanamikum. How you doing
mate? Long time. How you been? Long time
no see. Oh, I like that. That's a strong
firm shake. They they've done a study
and found that the men's men's handshake
has become really weak over the
centuries. It's the weakest it's ever
been actually. So it shows it. No, it's
h it's um what's opposite of Dave? uh
n yeah so yes it is alhamdulillah that
was a good uh firm handshake there so
brother and sisters alhamdulillah we are
going to be reacting to something it's
actually heartbreaking uh but the
zionist um movement would have got away
from this but not anymore you know it is
coming to an end and I believe it's the
beginning of the end of Zionism and
worldwide the whole world has seen this
and because now we have technology uh in
the sense where we've got mobile phones
alhamdulillah um you guys all probably
seen it I don't we are going to show you
the video but here's an interview of
Channel 4. Um, and this is how before
they knew that this actually the phone
was found in the dead man's pocket. Yes.
So before this happened, look at the
reaction of Channel 4 and look and
there's a moment in there she actually
stops speaking. I don't know if you've
seen it. She actually pauses. I don't
know if she's getting information about
it, but here we go. Let's watch for
herself in Sharon. Let's begin with
these bodies that have been found in
southern Gaza. Should there be an
investigation and why is Israel killing
emergency workers? So this is absolutely
incorrect. Uh there has been no such
case uh like that. Uh but how do you
know there has been mistakes you know uh
the events with the central world
kitchen that's been a great quickly you
just heard he said how do you know she
totally aired it. How how do you know?
She told because she thinks she can just
bluff like back in the days people don't
know the the atrocities that you're
doing to the gu people in Gaza and
Palestinians. Those days are over. Brave
mistake. Uh but the fact is I don't know
what case you're referring to. Uh but
every event that you get from Kamas, you
don't take it with a grain of salt. You
take it with a shovel of salt. Kamas has
been spreading propaganda since day one.
Yeah. I'm not talking about Hamas. I'm
I'm talking about the red cres. Hold on.
A a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a
a a a a research center, okay, from
London actually provide information and
evidence how kamas is inflating number,
how they're actually reducing the age of
some of the victims. You're not disusing
that 15 bodies have been found, have
you? That eight of them are red red
cresant workers.
Look, um I think that if I haven't heard
about this
case, look, every case that actually
happened, we investigate in depth. Okay?
uh if there's an investigation happening
regarding a case, I would be very short
and very uh um I would be very uh
cautious about making declarative and
statements as we've heard before. She's
googling it. That's what she's doing.
Did you just realize the video didn't
pause? That is a long silence. Have you
noticed that, bro? That was one long
silence. Just go a little bit back.
Yeah. She's she's useless. It's like why
are they interviewing some useless woman
that doesn't know what's going on?
Surely you message somebody and you go
we're going to be talking about this on
our show. Can you make it? And she goes
yes I can make it. And then she comes on
and say I I don't know what you're
talking about. Yeah. But this is the
downfall of the Zionism because the
thing is they are the reason why they
are so bold about this is because you
see when you have over overconfidence
and you think you're really going to go
and knock out opponents and you just
like you know I don't need to train for
him and he knocks you the hell out.
What's happening with Zionism and their
downfall is the fact that they're so
bold showing their war crimes because
they're thinking they are untouchable.
They're bold. Huh? Somebody else that's
bold.
Nice. Exactly. So, they are really bold
and that's the reason why they could
just come here and think, "Oh, I'm just
going to come chat some nonsense because
you know we we we have lobby AP pack you
know we pay everyone off. Those days are
over." But look at again let's just
watch it again how she goes silent for
quite a bit of time. Not disputing that
15 bodies have been found. Have you or
the eight of them are red red cresant
workers?
Look, um I think that if I haven't heard
about this
case, look at the tone, bro. This is
crazy. You know what happened? Somebody
in the back gave her something roasting
her and saying, "What the hell are you
doing?" No, no, no. They found this.
We're going to look like more bigger
pills than Alli looks without any hair.
Nice. Exactly. I even went to my barber
to shave my beard. He tried to do a
little fade. It didn't work. The thing
is this, bro, somebody gave an
information and said, "By the way, a
phone was found in the paramedic's
pocket. Watch what you're saying." And
what did she say? She went, "Look at her
tone. It was like, we investigate every
Bro, bro, she got caught out cold."
Okay. So, was that a woman? Yeah. Damn.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Now this is uh
LBC. Even the LBC is known as a kind of
far rightish, you know. No, it's not
known as far. No, but you know, it's
it's more of the thing, you know, it's
like center right. Yes. Yes. Yes. So,
look towards the right. Exactly. And
look, this is what they even had to say.
Look, this been exposed on a different
level. Footage in the pocket on the
phone of a dead man. It shows a red fire
engine and clearly marked ambulances
driving at night using headlights and
flashing emergency lights. If that phone
had not been found in that poor soul's
pocket, the IDF would still be claiming
that they had opened fire because the
vehicles were moving suspiciously.
Gunfire erupts and the screen goes
blank. 15 Palestinian paramedics and
rescue workers, including at least one
UN employee, were killed. The UN has
subsequently said that Israeli forces
shot the men one by one and then buried
them in a mass grave. There you go. now
and we know the footage cuz I don't want
to complate for censorship whatever it
is for that matter but you're very no
clear that man was saying the shahada
and you can hear the bullets yes one by
one and that's exactly what they done
and subhan Allah I mean what do you make
out of it bro like to me it just shows
me the hallmarks the signs of the end of
Israel it is it is you can see clearly
bro the whole world has woken up and it
is getting worse and worse and worse I
think firstly it's the it's the duas of
There's so many people in the kutuds of
so many people that you know day in day
out remember Gaza Palestine and uh
because of their duas because of you
know subhan allah the attention that the
um is giving alhamdulillah look look at
what James O'Brien was saying had it not
been for the phone this probably would
have been another story that Israel just
fs off you know what I mean and that
that woman/man that was uh being
interviewed by that you know simpish uh
journalist list then she probably would
have she/ he would probably have
continued you know um claiming that
she's got no clue what's going on. So
firstly, alhamdulillah that you know
something like this came out. Secondly,
when we hear that something like this
has come out, we go what a surprise.
Yeah. Because we know that this is one
of many things going on. But
alhamdulillah proof uh that media deems
to be uh worthy has come out otherwise
it would have been buried. Exactly. And
uh that's why Brah says alhamdulillah um
it is the beginning of the end for
Israel and you can see clearly that the
information the fact that she she was
she went silent for such a long time and
that information was given to her. You
saw how she changed her best or you know
we we investigate each individual case
whatever. So to me like subhan Allah
being caught in you know on camera as
these liars and subhan Allah Allah
subhana wa tala is exposing them with
their own hands like Allah tells us you
know that our own hands will testify
against us. Yes, our own hands are going
to speak. Our limbs are going to speak
out against this. But to see that in
real life where you can see an
individual showcasing their war crimes,
you know, and even I saw some um I don't
know if they were journalists, they were
outside the Metropolitan Police and they
were trying to get 10 um Brit Brit Brits
who went to join the IDF for war crimes.
So this is you know is it's inshallah
inshallah I just hope that it's the end
is coming. It's just I hope to live to
see it. There's there's a principle that
I think is useful for all all of us to
adopt which is balance. Yeah. Balance.
We're told in Quran that this um
is the middle um
yeah middle the middle nation we're in
the middle and alhamdulillah even in
anything and everything that you do if
you're in the middle. Yeah. Not in
either extremes alhamdulillah that's
good. But whenever you go overboard and
whenever you cross the bounds like
Israel is doing then eventually that's
exactly what happens. You are now the
orchestrator of your own downfall and
alhamdulillah and I pray that we hope to
see it and we hope to see Palestine
being free. I hope I hope man brothers
and sisters share this far and wide
inshallah and show the people inshallah
what's going on because the whole world
is waking up and you play a role in
this. Don't think oh you know big hu you
listen you play a role you sharing you
protesting you boycotting you being
vocal about it it only makes the people
more certain how evil these people are
Allah bless you
guysamlaykum the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said the one who builds
a masid for the sake of Allah Allah will
build for him a similar house in Jenna
we want to establish an amazing ing
masid for the sake of Allah subhana tala
in the country of Norway one of the most
northern countries of the world if you
donate for the sake of Allah to
establish this masid then he subhanahu
wa ta'ala will give you the reward
inshallah for every single person who
becomes a Muslim in this masid for every
single person who starts practicing the
dean from the da'wah that we give in
this masjid when they pray their salawat
when they fast in the month of Ramadan,
when they give in charity, every single
good deed that they do, you will
inshallah get the reward for that. If
you donate something small, maybe $100,
maybe $50 or whatever you can for the
sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said,
[Music]
Click on the link and donate now for the
sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
share the video. It's absolutely free
and you will get extra reward for
everyone.